une performance qui devrait compter à la
fin du championnat les verts seuil et se
sont offert ce dimanche devant leur
bouillant stade de porchefontaine le
leader menthe lit mais sur le terrain
cette dixième victoire de la saison en
division honneur a été longue à se
dessiner
les joueurs de la cité royale ne
menaient que 14 13 à la 50e minute et
versez y ont ensuite accéléré dans le
dernier quart d'heure pour remporter la
victoire devait de gagner chose faite 22
ça a été compliqué ils ont mis du rythme
de vendre a bien répondu
on marque trois beaux essais donc voilà
l'important c'est la victoire alors
l'histoire des bonus à la dernière
seconde
donc voilà on est content maintenant il
nous reste trois matches mathaf à faire
pour remonter dès cette saison fédérale
3 les versets y est deuxième du
championnat l'issue de cette 15e journée
devront réaliser une série de trois
victoires contre vitry vincennes et
bagneux défaite interdite les quatre
premiers du classement se tiennent en
quatre points
c'est une poule très serrée on n'avait
aucun match facile à gagner à domicile
comme à l'extérieur c'est dur l'objectif
de toute façon c'est je les dis enfin
c'est les phases finales
voilà on se pose pas trop de questions
en fait c'est gagner les matchs après
matchs et si on gagne ce qui nous reste
les trois derniers on n'y pense pas on y
pense mais on l'a fait d'avoir pris 20
points il ya quinze jours à gretz
tournan à g t au ça nous a remis un peu
les pieds sur terre et pour l'instant on
va aller chercher les phases finales et
c'est après on verra
le sprint final débutera le dimanche 19
mars les versets et se déplaceront sur
le terrain de vitry avant-dernier de
division honneur